what do you feel like should be the bare
minimum that's required from a man
in dating yeah and dating and and
someone like that wants to be your
boyfriend
s okay
yeah persistence Take Me Out
does he need to pay yeah yeah
what what percent of the time are you
talking about like once you're dating
should you pay 100 of the time the first
time the first date you should 100
definitely pay and then after that I
will like you know offer to pay but you
don't you know but you still meant to
say no it's fine I got this but you know
I will I hold my own so I will you know
offer to pay okay but like you're kind
of would you be annoyed if if he said
okay yeah go ahead I'll get up
I'll just pay and then I'll just be like
all right now I see you I see and will
you not see him after that or would you
still see him I'll probably give him one
more chance if he doesn't yes oh is it
cooked yeah
um for me just be like respect loyalty
you know
yeah stuff like that okay do you want me
to answer for a guy or for a girl oh
shoot uh we're gonna do guys an accident
here we go
um I want you to be a obsessed with me
to be honest yes like I want you to text
me call me all the time but then don't
be too much not overbearing so I have a
question
um is there someone you think of like
the guy you loved the most like one guy
that comes to mind yeah was he obsessed
with you yeah okay usually I find that
it's not the same like usually it's like
the guy that the girl likes the most
like isn't obsessed to them at all
really yeah yeah no I I feel like like
texting you daily
nice day it's not like your type up yeah
but like I I want I want the minimum
causation maybe or maybe minimal
standard like oh good morning have a
good night kind of thing okay it doesn't
have to be a full-on conversation all
the time but show me that you're
interested what about dates should he
pay a hundred percent of the time
um I mean if you're trying to quote me
like they call it all the ladies back in
the day you should be paying no like
well this is not free
but then obviously yes things like
evolve then I don't mind splitting or
going halfways you know so I have a
question
um are you a virgin
okay I just I would assume not just you
know but I don't know so do you do you
feel like it's it's fair that we require
traditional like the man paying when
we're not traditional women because
we're not virgins anymore
um that's a tough question
but you have to try before you buy no
are you going are you gonna go all the
way in without knowing what you're
getting yourself they used to they used
to and then they're all unhappy with
like 10 kids and just staying at home
taking care of the children not really
the divorce rate's higher now yeah now
because women want more we demand more
yeah but are we worth more hell yeah
really yeah especially now because women
are so independent you know that's why I
think our value is way higher I think
our value is lower than ever before in
all of human history yeah they're really
like the lowest value women possible on
the planet because men value Purity and
youth so the average age of first
marriage in the UK is 31 that's not
young and by 31 how many bodies you got
so so is that offering to the things
that men value
so it's like how can we say it's like
you're requiring a higher price for a
used product
not used experienced
because are you really going to get into
a relationship or a situation with
someone who doesn't have the experience
or the tools
to maybe you know make you a better
person or help you learn new things like
we're here to help each other so so I
think you've got to bring something to
the table Yeah but I think that's a very
feminine mindset because like in your
head as women I think we like project
our mindset onto men sometimes and so
and so like from a woman's point of view
you do want a guy that's experienced and
that you can learn from but like from a
man's point of view they prefer men
there are women that are more pure
then you want to be showered and babied
and taken care of like I'm your mother
so therefore maybe maybe the men you
pick you know that's not that's not all
men though I feel like all men have that
sense of like being they want to be
taken care of to a certain extent I
think they want someone that's like kind
and nurturing I would agree with you but
they also want a lot of similar
qualities like their mother
I mean I think they want someone that
would raise the kids so like they want
someone with motherly qualities because
if they want a wife they need someone to
raise the kids but like a guy that's
worth a damn he can take care of himself
unless you're dating like bombs
so do you actually believe that guys
like go for people who are like them
others yeah to a certain extent because
I feel like similar qualities like so so
I'm probably a rare case right I grew up
with just a single dad so no mama at all
so it's like I find that like statement
like a bit weird for me personally
obviously because I don't know what like
but did you have any like female role
models in your life nope but I had my
brother and my dad that's it so yeah
that's it and my dad did the cooking
ironing worked every day did everything
wow
yeah I guess I mean we're not all the
same you know yeah yeah I mean usually
we're speaking in general terms though
right well and if you if you if we're
gonna compare apples and oranges oranges
kids that come from single father out
homes tend to have better outcomes than
people that come from single mother home
so you could argue that like women or
men take care of themselves better than
women because like women we have we have
more debt we even though we make less
money
yeah yeah I think you're right because
when my when my parents divorced it was
like the reason why I went with my dad
was because he was financially stable
yeah but my mother wasn't so we that is
better for the kid in in at the end of
the day unless like you know your mom's
gonna marry a rich dude or something
like that I I don't know I feel like I
don't know with raising kids Finance yes
is helpful but then your morals uh the
most important because one person can
have a lot of money but if they have no
morals and no decorum no no sense of
like acting like a person then your
child is already and they learn that
from their dad though why does it have
to just no I never said that it has no
idea but I'm just saying even if they
have the finances doesn't mean that that
child is going to end up good or in a
good place
no no you're correct but even even so
it's like this the kid that's in a
single mother home is more at a
statistical disadvantage than a single
father home like he's more likely to
drop out of school more likely to go to
prison more like all the statistical
disadvantages that you have like tend to
be from single mother homes as opposed
is that more males or females or both
what do you mean like the child is a
male or female or uh well by and large
like men tend to be more aggressive I
mean um as
like a whole like they're more
disagreeable so they tend to go to jail
more so I would guess it's probably more
men okay
um so what about you guys do you think
what is the bare minimum that you feel
like is required from a female I'll let
uh go ahead thanks
um
somebody who's honest
and forthright
um
I think communication is the most
important thing in a relationship
absolute Trust
you know and trusts based on
communication understanding really
understanding each other
um so that's what that's what I've
always looked for first and foremost
to be honest I mean well I mean you know
obviously there are physical elements to
start off with but but then you know
that only lasts so long and after that
it really is about trust and
communication or communication and
building trust what about like cooking
cleaning do you feel like that's a bare
minimum from someone you would take
seriously
like if you're if you're paying for a
hundred percent of the dates let's just
say in the early stages what would you
require from the woman
it's a good interesting point I mean I I
personally I'm independent enough to be
able to cook and uh and all of that kind
of thing but
um I think that if a woman isn't able to
do that it's kind of a bit of a negative
thing which is not able to do that kind
of thing and you know in a lot of
instances
they make a virtue of not being able to
cook not being able to clean not working
sorry that isn't a virtue not for me as
far as I'm concerned I don't expect you
to do it but if you don't do it then
sorry what do you do so so
um if so if you're dating someone early
stages what do you expect from her
like just like how that we talk to the
women and they say I expect him to pay
early on like what do you expect
anything I think um
I think things have changed
very recently as far as as far as
expecting you know
to be taken to novikoff and uh and
you know that kind of thing that's
that's very very new you know I mean uh
you know I grew up during the 60s and
70s and I'm sure as hell didn't do that
kind of stuff I mean it was all 50 50.
it was all going dutch that's what they
called it and that's only changed very
recently
um
so uh no I I you know if
if a young lady was to um
to
uh
expect me to pay then uh they wouldn't
come as a big surprise to me but it
wouldn't be a positive it wouldn't be a
positive sign so so for for me with the
paying side of things usually I will pay
anyway like usually but what I actually
want like this is how I kind of Judge it
is for the woman to at least offer or at
least offer to pay half right she
doesn't actually have to pay half but
it's just kind of like a respect thing
like she would just be like no no I'll
pay half and and she doesn't have to you
can just then say no no don't worry I'll
deal with it and then that's fine but
it's just like I'd like her to do that
yeah in in terms of what I look for yeah
it's 100 physical first
um but after that I actually look at for
education but not in terms of like
academic what I mean is just like
educate and man as educated in in life
educated and like I really couldn't deal
with someone who's just like uneducated
about just how the world works or how
things things actually are so that's a
big like a huge turn off for me yeah
that's is a very good point what about
what about like what do you require that
she do if you're taking her out on dates
and courting her
um I mean for me honestly it's just like
having a good time will be up for for
doing things right if I want to do
things I want her to also want to do do
those do those things with me
um I don't actually require personally
like someone to cook or clean like I am
married and my wife does does do those
things she didn't before so like she she
had never cooked before she didn't clean
around the house she was just an English
teacher and the fact was when when we
lived lived together she just started
doing those things naturally so it's
kind of the same thing like she she just
decided okay I'm gonna help you out I'm
gonna gonna do these swings for you
so why do you think women complain more
about settling when we require more from
men and we can just exist
where men have to actually bring
something to the table and do things
speak into the max story because they're
never satisfied
I mean it's in the nature of women not
to be satisfied and so uh
so any uh anyone that they choose to
eventually end up with they will
consider that to be settling
I think maybe they're just always trying
to aim higher like
it's like and yeah like you said
something yeah but but like I I is is
the unrealistic thing right because I do
have a different experience my wife is
from China which which have more
Traditional Values like try get married
early things like that yeah
um and and they just don't like do the
Instagram stuff don't do Tinder really
like some do like I can't speak for the
whole whole of that but yeah it's just
the Tinder and like Instagram world has
changed the whole like view of
everything I feel like what do you guys
think who settles more men or women
definitely women okay why I think women
well women certain women get to this
certain point where they just can't be
asked to do the whole day in thing and
getting to know someone so they just
tend to settle or sometimes they settle
for the baby daddy that's given them
issues because they have a child
together
um I feel like because women you know
growing up we take such maybe that's why
we sell us more men are women I think
women I think women settle more
because one they might feel like oh okay
I'm getting older I'm lonely
so I'll just settle for any guy and as
well you know we've got a body clock and
you know we want to have kids and things
like that so maybe a thing where okay
I'll just sit with this guy so I can
have kids and just situations like that
where you just feel like oh there's a
lot of times you feel like oh there's no
good men out there so I don't think this
is good for the options
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible